I was like he didn't shoot the rest of
you hoes so I'm number one wait were you
he shot you in the head in the and then
you didn't lose Consciousness yeah it's
cracked my skull and so I wakes up in
the big his hole in the back of my head
I called 9-1-1 and called my girlfriend
they was like I don't know how the hell
you alive so how long were you
hospitalized I like two days they didn't
even sew it up he didn't he didn't go in
it just it just told the back of my head
out
you just tore the back of your head out
yeah and and they and and you just went
home yeah and nobody came to the
hospital to say who did this
um
I don't remember I don't remember the
police getting involved to be honest
with you because I just like you know I
just kept it to myself
and I was under age too it's you know I
look back over my life now and I was
like I was out let me when you pull in
Black in America let's be honest nobody
gives a [ __ ] and let's be honest when
you porn America nobody cares especially
when you black in America so nobody
cares I mean you got this 22 year old
man sleeping with a 12 year old picking
her up from elementary school everybody
turned their head and said oh well
somebody gotta buy some McDonald's or
mama can't
so nobody cared
this is unfucking believable
it's you're it's shocking to me and is
is let me tell you I'm surprised
you're waking me up because I would
imagine that if uh if a young 15 year
old I was 12 he was 22 married
speak to me I was I was at Dean Rush
Elementary
I was pregnant in elementary school at
12. uh-huh you went from elementary to
high school back in those days because
I'm 50. so now a pregnant 12 year old
comes in who's shot in the head and the
the hospital he shot me during the
summer so what does that mean so it
means that the teachers the school was
out so she had some time to heal but but
the the executives at the hospital don't
say there's a young woman with a with a
gunshot she I I had a baby at 14 out of
his man he walks in with his ID inside
my baby birth certificate nobody said
[ __ ] so why are you talking about The
Gunshot let's talk about the birth
certificate it ain't even done on me
until
um what city is this is this Atlanta
Atlanta so it's a big city a bet a big
Metropolis City I didn't care I had two
kids by him he signed both of that birth
certificate he's 22 on one I think in 23
on the other one does he have anything
to do I saw that I saw an episode where
he comes to visit oh he hates me and you
know it was good but I saw that episode
of your show where this was something
for in me the song once the the son
wants him to see him you don't want him
around and your husband doesn't want him
to show up at the house did he ever come
and see his kid at the house is that a
true story yeah it was just a way for me
to get my power back but he tried but he
didn't want anything you know after I
met my husband he was like well well
we're not messing around and no no more
let him be the daddy because you got to
remember I'm messing with a married man
but those are not he already had two
kids by his wife he had a total of 20
some kids by the time I left so my kids
it wasn't special
they was just at the top of the food
chain you know they was number three and
four
I don't know what that you are this is
absolutely shocking and it's absolutely
it's horrible it's horrible that there
was nobody around not one other person
like it's one thing that you live in
this
dark place of you know you are a victim
of you know your surroundings and your
environment but then you're saying in
the summer so the schools weren't around
but then the hospitals are there and
there's cops there no but but you're
saying it and it's true nobody cared
they care now they didn't care then do
they care now you think it's different
yeah now you're going to [ __ ] jail
you walk down there and sign a 12 year
old birth certificate I don't give a
[ __ ] if you how poor she is you're going
to jail but it took you talking about 30
years ago when my daughter's 35 36. so
you talking about 36 years ago
really
[Music]